先把自己能在这个社会上独立的存在这件事情放在第一位，
任何阻挡我在这个社会上独立的存在，
阻挡我在这个社会上自己去寻找自己的社会价值，
自己挣钱的人和事儿的话，
都是给我拖后腿的。
我是和我对象订婚了，
现在我研三要毕业，
我想找工作，
他想让我在他家里跟他一起做生意，
他说如果我找其他工作就分手。
我简略的说一下情况，
如果我俩是高中和大学同学，
老家在一个城市，
在一起六年吧，
中间分过，
他家是在一个二线城市，
开厂子10年了，
过年的时候我们都会回老家。
本科毕业后他工作两年了，
现在他是在自己家里工作，
能吃苦耐劳。
他爸去世五年了，
有个小八岁的弟弟，
他幺七二八十五K姐，
我幺六五五十五吧，
我俩感情还算挺好的，
每天也都视频，
现在面临这个毕业季，
我家里是普通家庭，
姐姐结婚了，
弟弟上大学不需要学费的那种，
我平时还经常被人夸好看，
父母不会成为我的负担，
有自己的保险，
他们妈也是希望我能回家一起做生意，
我觉得我俩一起做生意风险非常大，
我自己也没有安全感啊，
全。
感是自己给自己的，
我若果跟他在一起，
感情我给不了自己安全感，
我俩是没有原则性的问题，
经历了一些事儿，
小的事情也积攒一些失望，
就比如说我在他家里住的时候，
有两次晚上吵架，
他就说让我走，
抢我手机要买票，
第二天就走，
衣柜如果乱的话，
还有晒衣服不整齐的话，
他就很生气，
他自己本来卧室也很乱，
就是说他天天上班这么忙吗？
他自己不愿意，
说是想找个能把家务做好的老婆，
我该是自己找工作，
还是在他家里一起做生意，
这个选择我想听听姐姐给我分析一下，
我觉得自己一定要找自己，
比如说你性格呀，
你的专业呀，
你的这个研究生的学历呀，
找跟你匹配的工作，
不然的话，
像你去他的厂子里面去干，
那开多少钱呢？
干什么工作是他虽然说是以后我管钱，
只是一个口头上的说的，
他家条件应该比较好的，
他没给我告诉过他家里年收入，
但是他也不错，
弟弟一年上私立学校学费就有5万起步，
我觉得如果说你自己，
你如果说实在想跟他在一起，
哪怕是说在他的家乡，
你自己整点找到自己的工作，
是吧，
因为你是研究生毕业嘛，
你有这么好的。
条件摆在这儿，
咱找个差不离的工作，
找个铁道碗事业编或者干嘛的工作的话，
哪怕你有富裕出来的时间精力，
你花在这个厂子里都好过，
说你什么底牌都没有，
直接去人家厂子里面打工去。
对我想的也是他现在就比较执拗了，
说如果要找工作就面临分手，
那我在想现在该怎么跟他沟通，
想向姐姐请教一下。
你说我也想我们俩走的长远，
但从长远的考虑的话，
我必须得有一份不依赖于你而独立存在的工作，
这样的话，
我们才是平等的地位，
否则的话，
如果我去你的厂子里面打工，
那你始终是老板，
我始终是员工，
难免会有一种不平等，
而我来你的这个地方，
我娘家又不在这边儿，
我难免会有这种委屈感。
其实从长远来看的话，
我自己找一份工作，
哪怕清闲一点，
哪怕收入没有那么高，
但是我可以在工作之余的时间可以帮成你，
都是好的，
你就这么说呗，
对，
我之前也大概这么说了，
我也一直是这么想的，
他是想的是也做一下外贸，
赚几年钱就不用有太大的压力，
他的概念就是人赚钱可能就那几年，
赚到了人生中大部分钱之后就安安稳稳过日子，
那他没有必要拖你，
像水呀，
他如果这么有本事的话，
他当老板的话，
他雇员工不就得了吗？
啊，
难道像你这样的员工不是社会上一你抓一大把吗？
为什么非得要把你绑在这个厂子里呢？
他是担心别人把订单带走，
那招员工的话招业务员，
那你觉得就你俩这作坊能几年就把这钱挣了，
这我觉得也是，
我个人还是觉得我们女性啊，
一定要先有一份不依赖于任何一个男人而独立存在的生存的基础才行，
不然的话这关系不好处啊，
如果男方有遗传臭白头的话，
这你觉得这以后孩子有多大的眼彩呀？
就是我觉得你这还好吧，
你染就行了吧，
你现在你直接染成灰色的花白色的不也多了去了吗？
啊，
我在想，
如果是女孩的话，
她有白头发会不会自卑？
这个点考虑的有点远了，
其实也可以染头发呀，
也可以像我似的带个补发片啊，
也没啥哦，
好的，
那我寻思这两天就把这个事情给他说清楚，
如果她真不愿意，
那就只能是分手了，
你就青春年华的是不是研究生第一页真的姑娘，
先把自己能在这个社会上独立的存在这件事情放在第一位，
任何阻挡我在这个社会上独立的存在，
阻挡我在这个社上自己去寻找自己的社会价值，
自己挣钱的人和事儿的话，
都是给我拖后腿的。
那如果分手的话，
那相当于是退婚，
退婚了，
把所有彩礼都退回去生啊，
姐姐，
那肯定得退呀那。
五金呢，
那也得退呀，
改口费呢也得退呀，
好的，
那买的礼物，
礼物看是消耗品，
如果说是消耗品，
比如说买了手机用了，
那一般也就不退了，
好的，
那我知道了，
好先这样啊，
好，
谢谢姐姐，
拜拜，
祝你开心好，
再见，
拜拜。
我记得我看那个好像是叫13幺的一个综艺的节目啊，
有一个采访，
本来是采访这个老先生，
这个老先生是非常知名的一个画家，
顺带手的闲聊问了一下这个老先生的配偶说如果有来生，
你还会跟他在一起吗？
他说不，
他说没有来生，
如果有来生的话，
我就简单的想要一份自己的工作就很好了。
那一瞬间其实我心好疼好揪心，
就是男生可能理解不了吧，
我觉得那个主持人那一瞬间也未必能理解得了这位奶奶，
她的那个心酸她未必能理解的了，
但是我们作为女性是特别能理解她那份心酸的，
就她这一辈子都是在配合，
在支持，
在辅助她的丈夫，
虽然她的丈夫在这个江湖上，
在绘画这个领域拿到了那么高的成就，
但这位女性，
她在这个过程当中，
她牺牲了自己，
所以说她说如果有来生的话，
我不会跟她结婚，
如果有来生的话，
我就要一份我自己的工作，
简简单单就好了，
听到的时候真的好揪心，
其实她本身她自己就很优秀，
她是那个年代啊，
你想那个年代。
她就是自己是拿到了高文凭，
而且她是自己有工作的，
她在自己的事业上向她投入家庭，
照顾这个丈夫，
配合丈夫的这些时间和精力的话，
那么她在自己的事业上，
她得到的成就未必就比不上她的丈夫。
我是这么理解的，
我不知道有多少姐妹会有这种同感，
就如果说她把她的时间精力全都花在自己的事业上，
她呢？
在事业上能获得的成就未必就比她的丈夫低，
可惜没有来生。
这段话也是说给刚才那个妹妹听的，
一定要有一份自己的独立的，
就是能吃饱饭的，
但未必是做什么大事业，
未必是做什么促进人类发展，
改善人类环境，
未必是做那么大的事业，
但是一定要有一份自己的能够吃饱饭的家伙。
事儿记得点赞关注哦。